à quoi pensez-vous j'arrive au pluriel
monsieur sans lui pas de complexité donc
pas de vie monsieur vous avez raison
c'est essentiel pluriel de train par
exemple sérail équitablement
ah oui pour moi parce que un train
déraille
monsieur merci
quel effet fait je vous attendais tu es
né où je suis bien pour hier c'est au
sein pour hier c'est un village qui est
célèbre par cette histoire c'est dans la
vallée de l'arc c'est c'est là où a eu
lieu la bataille d'aix en provence qui
oppose et marius empereur romain
quelques 40 ans avant jésus-christ au cm
on est au top
et bien il y en a qui disent les témoins
les tétons mais parce que c'est moi
d'être au top
voyez c'est ça s'appelle pour rien parce
qu'il ya eu tellement de morts que
c'était pourri c'est pour ça et à côté
un petit village aussi qui s'appelle
pour sûr et a brandi poussive et pour
six ou c'est pareil c'était l'endroit où
on mettait le fumier de cheval de brebis
tout ça donc c'est une bataille
gigantesque gigantesque je suis né le
cul tourner vers le mont aurélien et la
tête d'un à ses deux victoires et qu'est
ce qui a fait toute ta vie là-bas pour
hier alors je vais pas rester là je veux
dire je suis allé à l'école moment
qu'est ce que tu as fait après le lycée
alors après je me suis marié et alors
j'ai eu un petit alors c'était bonnard
parce que si c'est l'époque de te marier
leptine et c'est au moins neuf mois
après au moins est là bas on avait fait
passer ne peut pas gagner ramon et en
bohême enfin le progrès dans la rue et
déjà écouter plus tard ils sont mariés
au moi de jouer
toujours en octobre au bout de 4 et 5 en
ligue 1 mais c'est pas possible
autrement
wallace était alors après une facture ce
petit sur le dos pour of ce petit bras
comme souvent c'est aussi comme cela
s'est fait après la après
je suis rentré dans une banque à la peau
pour karine casse
j'avais il y avait une annonce il me
faisait ni pourquoi pas ouais puis ça a
marché surestime je suis resté 18 ans à
corps mais c'est là que je suis arrivé
au lavandou ces professionnels à ces
professionnels le départ j'étais
directeur de la bande colorée un cutter
là je te dis pas tu es le roi du
découvrir c'était sympa et que les gens
roulent trop alors un la banque ne
comprenais pas moi je et à dire vous
pouvez en avoir 50 ou 100 de guyane et
ça arrivait pas au dixième de ceux qui
me refusent l autre côté tu comprends
manufrance sais combien c'est
malheureusement c'est d'autres milliards
pour une banque quelles différences
moi je disais bord d'autres mieux le
découvrir
même avec ken levine clients c'est pas
vrai ça ne sais pas c'était moins cher
que la ciotat est alors donc t'as fait
ça et après tu t'es arrêter de
travailler
non qu'est ce que tu as fait prier je
m'occupe au milan je m'occupe d'une
maison de la caisse alors qu'est ce que
tu fais ta vie alors de bénéficier de
perdre le moins de temps possible
ouais parce que bon dans le midi c'est
dur ouais ouais vous avoir du mal à gand
mais non c'est eux c'est une
c'est des conneries d'entendre ça tu
vois je te dis parce que ronny ron est
jugée à travers une culture pagnolesque
ah bon on nous juge sur les a priori qui
sommes fous par exemple par exemple la
partie de cartes de pagnol ouais y'a un
cocu un kart fig
mais là il ya déjà une erreur si elle
n'avait que 1 progresse de cocu ça
serait quand même un gros malheureux ça
fait 25 % mais voilà première main
deuxième main les tricheurs
ouais panis et qui samba et quitter la
table parce que c'est harry triche mais
ça n'existe pas c'est pas avant non les
provençaux sont pas comme ça non d'abord
on ne triche pas aux cartes
un riche beaucoup de choses mais pas au
cas par cas
ça c'est la deuxième ris tout tout tout
l'oeuvre de pagnol nous classe si tu
veux pas aux yeux de la france entière
c'est une grosse erreur tu vas la paix
ce nom pourquoi j'ai tourné le dos à la
mer je sais pas ce que je sais pas nager
d'abord un et puis c
jamais été attiré par le bronzage ni par
la mer ni moins à la chasse j'y allais
un chalet mais gégé
j'ai eu un gros malheur j'ai perdu ma
chienne et ça m'a fait de la peine et
jerry surtout pour elle et puis je suis
poli ça fait de la graine ça a été un
des plus grands chagrins de service
certainement mais qu'est ce que tu fais
alors en dehors de ces bains je m'occupe
d'eux des jeunes qui a eu la bonne idée
de choisir mon établissement pour passer
votre calme en dehors de ça j'ai une vie
un peu je suis
je fais pas de politique je suis adjoint
au maire au lavandou a quand même
ouais c'est pas de la politique l'a pas
dit mais les permis de construire c'est
toi qui les donnent moi je suis à jaws
pour avoir je ne sais pas responsable de
ce qui se passe alors je veux pas dire
que je me désolidarise de ce qui se fait
mais bon j'en donnerai - les permis de
construire soit vous attend pas moins
mais j'en donnerai je serai peut-être un
peu plus regardants sur la qualité de
légende et même des dix mois tu vois
qu'elle est mort sa provence est malade
n'est pas morte et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de finale andy tube abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus